[موسيقى]
إنها استجابة الجسم الشديدة للعدوى،
الإنتان هو حالة تهدد الحياة
وتتطلب رعاية طبية عاجلة
لمنع تلف الأعضاء والوفاة.
لا أعتقد أن عامة الناس
يفهمون حقًا مدى خطورة الإنتان،
وقد يكون من الصعب التعرف عليه.
مجموعة واسعة من الأعراض بما في ذلك
الارتباك أو الارتباك، وضيق في
التنفس، وارتفاع معدل ضربات القلب، والحمى، والارتعاش،
والألم الشديد، والجلد الرطب أو المتعرق.
أظهر مسح عام 2022 لأكثر من 5000 مستشفى أمريكي أن 73٪ فقط أبلغوا عن
وجود مجموعة مخصصة مكلفة
بمراقبة ومراجعة رعاية مرضى الإنتان و
النتائج ولكن في El Camino Health
يقول المسؤولون إن الجهاز الجديد يساعد في
تحسين تصحيح تدفق رعاية المرضى وهو
تغيير اللعبة حقًا في إدارة
علاج الإنتان، حيث يلتصق الجهاز
برقبة المريض
وينقل البيانات في الوقت الفعلي لاسلكيًا إلى
فريق الرعاية الصحية مما يسمح لهم بمراقبة
السوائل  تعد الإدارة جزءًا أساسيًا من
علاج الإنتان، مما لا شك فيه أنه نظرًا
لأننا تمكنا من
تقييم المرضى بسرعة كبيرة باستخدام هذه الأداة، فقد
تمكنا من إدارة
خطة العلاج الخاصة بهم بسرعة
وكفاءة أكبر وإنقاذ الأرواح نتيجة لذلك
من أجل الصحة  أنا أندي
جثر